FACE.
WHAT IS THAT PROBLEM?
AND THEIR PLAN NOW?
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN IS A
REPUBLICAN RESENTING OHIO IN THE
MIDDLE OF ALL OF THIS, AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU FOR
COMING ON.
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION, THE FINAL
DEBATE OVER THE WALL, THE FINAL
HOURS OF THE REPUBLICAN CONGRES
CONGRESS, WHY NOW?
LIKE TWO YEARS LATER?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, WE SHOULD HAVE
DONE IT EARLIER, WE SHOULD HAVE
DONE IT ON MARCH WITH THE BIG
SPENDING BILL, WE TOLD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WE WOULD.
THEN DECEMBER, DIDN'T DO IT,
THEN WE SAID WE    WE WILL DO IT
THEN WE SAID WE    WE WILL DO IU
THEN WE SAID WE    WE WILL DO ID
THEN WE SAID WE    WE WILL DO IR
SUMMER 21ST, WE DID IT TONIGHT
IN THE HOUSE.
JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO, IT
PASSED, EVEN THOUGH LAST WEEK IN
THE OVAL OFFICE, NANCY PELOSI
SAID THE HOUSE CAN'T GET PEOPLE
TO PAST A BORDER SECURITY WALL,
FUNDING FOR A BORDER SECURITY
WALL, WE JUST DID A FEW MINUTES
AGO, 217 VOTES.
THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE 185.
WE PASSED IT IN THE HOUSE, THAT
IS STEP ONE, NOW GOES BACK TO
THE SENATE, AND WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS FROM THERE.
WE NEED TO STAND FIRM ON THIS
BECAUSE, AS YOU SAID, AS THE
PRESIDENT'S HAND, THIS IS A
CENTRAL PROMISE WE MADE TO
VOTERS IN 2016.
THIS IS OUR LAST, BEST CHANCE TO
DO WHAT EVERYONE KNOWS IS GOOD,
COMMON SENSE.
EVERYONE BUT THE DEMOCRATS
KNOWS, GOOD, COMMON SENSE.
>> Tucker: IT IS FAIR FOR THE
REST OF US TO PRESS DEEPER AND
ASK WHY IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, IT
SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED, YOU WOULD
HAVE PREFERRED FOR IT TO HAPPEN
EARLIER.
>> OF COURSE, RIGHT.
>> Tucker: BUT IT DIDN'T, BUT
THAT MEANS PEOPLE PREVENTED A
PAIRED SPEAKER RYAN WAS ONE OF
THEM.
WHO ELSE?
SO THE REST OF US CAN KEEP
SCORE.
>> TO DO SOMETHING THAT REALLY
COUNTS AND HAS LASTING VALUE AND
MEANING IS NEVER EASY.
SO ANYTHING WORTH DOING IS
ALWAYS DIFFICULT, BUT CONGRESS
ALWAYS HAS A WAY OF TRYING TO
TAKE THE LEAST RESISTANT ROUTE
AND DO THE EASY THING.
THAT IS WHY IT HAPPENED, I THIN
THINK.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU WERE FOR
IT, BUT THE TAX BILL WAS
DEFINITELY HARD.
THERE WAS A LOT OF OPPOSITION TO
IT, AND THE LEADERSHIPS DECIDED
THEY ARE GETTING THIS DONE, THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT TRUMP RAN ON,
BUT THEY WANTED IT, AND THEY GOT
IT DONE.
THEY CAME ON A SHOW AND MADE THE
CASE FOR IT.
DIDN'T DO THAT WITH A WALL, WHY?
I THINK IT IS FAIR TO KNOW,
SINCE YOU ARE ON THE INSIDE AND
WE ARE NOT, WHO PREVENTED THAT?
>> I THINK THE INTENSITY WAS
MORE FOR THE TAX CUTS THAT IT
WAS FOR REPLACING -- REPEALING
AND REPLACING OBAMACARE AND
BUILDING A BORDER SECURITY WALL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE HAVE
BEEN PUSHING, AND LIKE I SAID,
WE JUST PASSED A BILL THAT PUTS